l'ordre du jour donc appelle la question
orale de Monsieur rené Beaumont à
Monsieur le Ministre chargé des
transport de la mer et de la
Pêche monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues décidément monsieur le
ministre la RCEA passionne de plus en
plus les élus de saéloir
puisque après la question orale posée
par jean-patric courtois en octobre
dernier la mienne milieu milieu janvier
2013 et celle qui n'est peut-être pas
tout à fait issue du hasard il y a 5
jours à l'Assemblée nationale du nouveau
député du maconnaet je reviens encore
une fois devant vous monsieur le
ministre
regrettant malgré tous vos talents que
le ministre spécialiste ne soit pas là
parce que c'est un dossier qui est assez
lourd et qui dure depuis longtemps et
qu'il connaît
bien de cette dernière intervention je
m'étonne qu'il ait fallu 13 mois au
ministre en charge des transports pour
décider unilatéralement je cite la
concession autoroutière serait une
solution juridiquement
inacceptable pour pour certaines
sections et notamment en saéloire dont
je suis
l'élu ce problème a été de nombreuses
fois abordé par le passé avec vos
prédécesseurs puisque c'est un vieux
dossier ainsi que lors du grand débat
sur
le sur la concession autoroutière entre
entre Macon et et montmarau et aucune
interdiction juridique n'a été sur ce
dossier jusqualors
prononcé en effet des compensations
avaient été proposées en tenant compte
de la mauvaise qualité des des liaisons
alternativ et notamment du finance et
également pardon du financement déjà
très important des collectivités locales
sur les tronçons déjà réalisé ces
compensations se traduisaient par des
gratuités pour tous les déplacements
locaux
par ailleurs nous attendons
désespérément que soit enfin publié les
conclusions du rapport du Conseil
Général du développement
durable qui a été chargé par Monsieur le
Ministre d'étudier justement les
d'autres solutions alternatives qui
avaient été proposé par par le passé et
qui devait ses conclusions devaient être
rendues fin fin d'année 2012 d'abord
puis ensuite début 2013 elles ne le sont
toujours pas on peut s'interroger sur
son retard de publication qui ne
pourrait être dû qu'à une volonté de
terire des conclusions qui n'irait pas
dans le sens de certains élus de sonéire
et qui dénonceraiit clairement
l'irréalité financière totale d'une
construction à deux fois de voix entre
Macon et montmarot financé par l'écotaxe
poids lourd et des apports de l'État et
du conseil
général monsieur le ministre si on ne
réalise pas rapidement une vraie de fois
de voix gratuite ou non sur cette sur la
totalité de cetteé itinéraire nous
continuerons à perdre entre 25 et 30
citoyens par an citoyens ou étrangers
d'ailleurs mais 35 25 à 35 morts si vous
préférez sur cette axe et parallèlement
nous privverons tout l'ouest de la
sonéloire et la totalité du département
de l'alliier d'une desserte autoroutière
totalement justifiée par les 16 à 18000
véhicules jour et une densité de poids
lourd frisant les 50
% pour faire sourire dans le même
secteur de on a bien réalisé l'autoroute
montargie cône cône surloire qui
n'abrite que quelques milliers de
véhicules par jour mais il est vrai que
la Nièvre n'est pas la sonéoire et
l'Allier vous avez pensé jeudi dernier
vous avez proposé jeudi dernier un plan
de relance pour la RCEA il ne pourra
nous satisfaire que s'il s'élève à 950
millions d'euros coûte de la mise à deux
fois de voix sur laquelle tout le monde
est d'accord sur la total ité de
l'itinéraire je doute qu'on puisse
trouver ces crédits publics aujourd'hui
et je vais terminer naïvement monsieur
le ministre en vous demandant une fois
de plus dans quel délai précis vous
allez pouvoir nous présenter ce plan de
relance nouveau qui me semble tout à
fait utopique je le dis franchement
précis c'est dire mieux que quelques
semaines de de c'était l'expression
votre expression jeudi dernier par
exemple engage pour la rentrée de
septembre le 1er
septembre je conclurai simplement
par sévère de la
Fontaine ne faut-il que délibérer la
cour en conseiller
foisonne est-il besoin d'exécuter on ne
rencontre plus
personne merci Monsieur beaumon la
parole est à monsieur Guillaume
gar merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur baaumon je veux d'abord
excus excuser l'absence de Frédéric
cuvilier le ministre des Transports qui
est retenu ce matin au Bourget vous
interroger sur le mode poétique même le
ministre des Transports sur la mise à
deux fois de voix de la route Centre
Europe
Atlantique cet axe mêle en effet des
trafics locaux à un important trafic
longue distance qui pose et vous l'avez
dit hein de de grandes difficultés à la
fois de circulation mais aussi de
sécurité et dans le même temps nous le
savons tous cet axe joue un rôle
déterminant dans l'accessibilité et la
desserte de nombreux de très nombreux
territoires c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement le confirme ce matin c'est
que nous sommes déterminés à moderniser
cette
infrastructure les investissements
nécessairirees pour achever la mise à
deux fois de voix de cette partie sont
évalué aujourd'hui à 1 milliard d'euros
le précédent gouvernement avait décidé
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs de recourir à
la mise en concession de cet axe ce qui
a soulevé l'inquiétude et on peut le
comprendre des usagers locaux du fait de
l'insturtio d'un péage s'agissant de la
mission qui a été confiée au Conseil
Général de l'environnement et du
développement durable les conclusions
définitives devrai être rendu très
prochainement par ailleurs sur la base
des premières orientations qui ont été
identifiées Frédéric cuvilier a engagé
une concertation avec les collectivités
concernées sur à la fois les solutions
d'aménagement mais aussi les solutions
de financement alors je puis vous dire
ce matin que le dossier avance une
décision devrait pouvoir intervenir dans
les prochaines semaines et l'objectif
l'objectif il est bien d'établir enfin
en partenariat avec les collectivités
locales de l'alliier mais aussi de la
sonnéloire un projet qui soit réaliste
et donc réalisable vous pouvez compter
sur l'engagement du gouvernement
l'engagement du ministre des Transports
pour faire aboutir ce projet et pour
mettre fin à une situation qui dure
depuis trop longtemps je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur
Beaumont court monsieur monsieur baaumon
je vous laisser largement dépasser votre
temps tout à l'heure merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président je très court
monsieur le ministre d'abord pour vous
remercier bien sûr de votre réponse
qui confirme les déclarations du
ministre il y a quelques jours à
l'Assemblée nationale je vous ai dit que
c'est déclaration déjà ne me ne me
satisfaisait pas vous avez évoqué à
l'instant que il les population étaient
inquiète parce que il y av y allit avant
un page c'est assez bizarre parce que
les populations de sonéir sont inquiètes
mais celles de l'allié ne le sont pas
c'est je crois celles de sonéloir ont dû
être un peu agité je j'imagine de pour
pour pour protester c'est un petit peu
ça qui se passe parce que et qui couvre
un qui masque un petit peu la réalité de
ce dossier en tout cas j'ai j'ai j'ai
enregistré votre engagement celui du
gouvernement je l'attends avec
impatience merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur baumon